[Música]
los Juegos Olímpicos son cada cuatro
años y una celebración del deporte y un
freno a los conflictos del mundo pero
muchas veces en la historia la traigo a
olímpica hacia roto y trágicamente como
durante el juego Olímpicos de Munich
hace ya 50 años el 5 de septiembre de
1972 en medio de la noche un comando
terrorista palestino entró en la Villa
Olímpica Y tomó como Rehenes a 11
miembros de la delegación israelí el
asedio duró 18 horas los terroristas que
decían pertenecer al movimiento
septiembre negro exigían la liberación
de todos los palestinos encarcelados en
Israel tras matar a dos Rehenes la
negociación de un avión para salir del
país Con Suso prisioneros pues no tuvo
mucho éxito la policía alemana intentó
una operación de rescate en el
aeropuerto pero su mala preparación
terminó en un desastre todos los rehenes
fueron asesinados cinco de los ocho
terroristas fueron abatidos Y un policía
de Alemania occidental fue asesinado al
mismo tiempo en el estadio olímpico la
competencia de toma clásica se
desarrollaba según lo previsto y solo al
día siguiente los juegos fueron
suspendidos durante 24 horas para rendir
un breve homenaje a las víctimas un mes
después de este atentado los tres
terroristas sobrevivientes fueron
liberados a cambio y otros Rehenes tras
El secuestro de un avión de lufthansa no
fue hasta 2021 que durante la ceremonia
de apertura de los Juegos Olímpicos se
rindió un nuevo homenaje a los atletas
asesinados nuestros reporteros o fueron
a Munich tras 50 años de esta masacre
veamos este reportaje
[Música]
ahora sabemos más sobre el ultimátum
fijado por los secuestradores y sus
exigencias
los guerrilleros exigen la liberación de
todos los prisioneros palestinos
detenidos en Israel antes del mediodía
amenazan con fusilar a Los Rehenes si no
se cumplen sus exigencias
en Munich en la Villa Olímpica poco o
nada ha cambiado desde 1972
cuando Peter lille entró por primera vez
en este complejo arquitectónico hace 50
años
estaban empezando su carrera como
periodista deportivo un viento de
cambios soplaba en la ciudad
era reportero en la Villa Olímpica pero
también me encargaba de cubrir las
pruebas de lucha libre cerca de ahí
pero mi parte favorita fue este campus
universitario era tan alegre y bonito
con estos colores brillantes por todas
partes
esas fueron realmente las olimpiadas de
1972 para mí
los Juegos Olímpicos debían ser un
reflejo de la Alemania occidental
después de la guerra una nación
acogedora y benévola pero todo cambió en
la madrugada del 5 de septiembre
[Música]
es el edificio donde tuvo lugar la toma
de Rehenes
Me parece que fue allá arriba por ese
techo que la policía trató de intervenir
por primera vez los Juegos Olímpicos
eran transmitidos en directo en todo el
mundo
500 millones de personas siguieron la
toma de Rehenes por televisión
los miembros del Comando también vieron
en directo el despliegue de la policía
en la Villa Olímpica
la placa conmemorativa en honor a las
víctimas sigue siendo cuidada por sus
familias
detrás de estos 11 nombres hay familias
que siguen sufriendo actualmente
personas que perdieron a sus esposos a
sus amigos a sus padres se habla muy
poco de eso
para mí el principal error que se
cometió fue no haber cortado la
electricidad del apartamento si
hubiéramos hecho eso los terroristas
nunca habrían sabido lo que estaba
pasando
en Israel la primera ministra se negó a
negociar con los terroristas pero esta
toma de Rehenes que se convirtió en una
masacre hizo tambalear la confianza en
la que vivían los israelíes tras la
rotunda victoria de la Guerra de los
seis días cinco años atrás Ya el chamán
estaba en la escuela cuando se enteró de
la muerte de su padre Tenía solo 12 años
esta era su llave del apartamento si se
fija bien dice
[Música]
Olympic Park
1972 Colón y 31
josef sobreviviente del holocausto de
origen rumano era árbitro de lucha libre
un amante de la vida siempre de buen
humor es un héroe para su familia y para
muchos israelíes en 1972 fue a Alemania
para sus terceros Juegos Olímpicos un
país al que ya él culpa de la muerte de
su padre
los alemanes sabían que se Estaba
preparando un ataque terrorista pero
decidieron ignorar esa información
durante el ataque cuando fueron tomados
como Rehenes lo único que hicieron los
alemanes fue darles un helicóptero para
que salieran de la Villa Olímpica todo
lo que querían era preservar su
celebración Olímpica
durante 50 años la ha acompañado la foto
de su padre acribillado a balazos tras
la toma de Rehenes
una imagen que también está grabada en
la memoria de Hansel
lo recuerdo muy bien
lo voy acurrucado en el helicóptero
muerto con la cabeza inclinada hacia
adelante
en 1972 hannes cumplía el servicio
militar en el aeropuerto de fuselbrook
donde los secuestradores fueron llevados
con sus víctimas para abandonar el país
este acontecimiento del que no habló
durante 50 años lo ha acompañado toda su
vida
estaba en la antigua torre de control
que se ve ahí
con la letra c
todo ocurrió frente a ese edificio
durante el tiroteo Estaba encerrado en
el edificio detrás de la ventana lo vi
todo
en este año de conmemoración el museo de
la ciudad dedica una exposición a los
Juegos Olímpicos y al Atentado
La primera competencia internacional
organizada por la Alemania de la
posguerra debía encarnar Exactamente lo
contrario de las olimpiadas nazis de
Berlín de 1936 por tanto los agentes de
policía que se encontraban en el lugar
no llevaban armas llaman la atención sus
uniformes azul cielo diseñados por el
diseñador de moda francés
la policía preparó una emboscada en el
aeropuerto pero solo contaban con cinco
tiradores novatos frente a los 8
terroristas del comandante la catástrofe
se veía venir pero las autoridades
alemanas hasta ahora no han reconocido
sus errores
hay un informe oficial que se presentó
unos 10 días después del ataque y la
conclusión de este informe dice
claramente no teníamos alternativas
Hicimos lo correcto
y sin embargo con tan poco tiempo para
investigarlo nadie podía entender
realmente lo que había pasado no se
había entrevistado a todos los Testigos
la policía así como el Ministerio del
interior querían protegerse por encima
de todo para mí Es evidente que querían
ante todo no pensar más en ese suceso
para mí Lo peor es eso
la reacción de las autoridades
ya entonces Y hasta ahora actuaron como
si este atentado no fuera de su
incompetencia pasó y ya está
los Juegos Olímpicos se reanudaron el
día después de la masacre no fue hasta
2017 que se construyó un monumento
oficial en el parque olímpico de Munich
en la época del atentado menos de 30
años después del fin del régimen nazi
Alemania aún no había hecho su trabajo
de memoria histórica tenía una relación
ambigua con el estado de Israel
según el historiador purín que ayudó en
la creación del monumento las señales de
advertencia fueron simplemente ignoradas
no hubo planificación alguna como si no
fuera posible que ocurriera un atentado
y es aún más extraño porque ya había
habido una serie de atentados en 1970
contra una residencia para ancianos
judía pero también contra el mostrador
de la aerolínea Nacional de Israel en el
aeropuerto de Munich entre otros y sin
embargo nadie pensó en eso no había
ninguna unidad antiterrorista en esa
época
las autoridades alemanas aprendieron
algo de esta masacre crearon los
comandos especiales de intervención
policial Martín texmestor que se había
ofrecido como voluntario para la
seguridad de La Tribuna oficial de
Múnich se unió inmediatamente a esta
tropa de élite y dirigió la sección de
Berlín durante 25 años
esa es una visita oficial al comando de
intervención debe ser de 1974 o 75
para los servicios de seguridad alemanes
la masacre de Munich fue una llamada de
advertencia también fue el comienzo de
la lucha contra el terrorismo en
retrospectiva Martín textor cree que la
policía hizo lo que pudo con los escasos
recursos de los que disponía
más adelante la creación de unidades
especiales como el gsg 9 demostró que
podíamos manejar la toma de Rehenes como
el mojadillo donde todo terminó Bien
también en Berlín demostramos que
nuestra unidad era capaz de hacer frente
a este tipo de cosas
que también podíamos luchar eficazmente
contra la violencia criminal
y sin embargo si el atentado de los
Juegos Olímpicos no se repetirá hoy no
podría prometer que fuéramos capaces de
resolver la situación al 100%. es como
con la guerra
y sin embargo medio siglo después sigue
habiendo zonas grises en torno al
Atentado
Peter Leal continuó su carrera en
eventos deportivos Esta es la primera
vez que vuelve al periódico de Munich
para revisar la edición del 6 de
septiembre de 1972 en la que colaboró
[Música]
el periódico publicó primero el titular
basándose en lo que se sabía todos los
rehenes están a salvo y así se imprimió
y luego tuvimos que hacer una edición
especial el mismo día para decir que
estaban todos muertos
Cuando uno piensa en eso es difícil de
creer lo que pasó
Walter dirk Que investigó El Atentado
ponente La de juicio el papel del
gobierno Alemán de la época sobre todo
en la liberación de los terroristas Solo
dos meses después de la masacre de
Munich
hay muchas preguntas en respuesta
especialmente Respecto a los tres
terroristas que fueron intercambiados en
octubre
hasta el día de hoy se especula que la
toma de Rehenes del avión que llevó a su
Liberación podría haber sido orquestada
porque Alemania quería deshacerse de los
terroristas sobrevivientes lo antes
posible la verdad sigue sin conocerse
actualmente
lo único cierto es que las familias de
las víctimas nunca vieron a los
responsables del atentado tener un
juicio el mosad israelí asesinó a una
docena de miembros de la organización
Palestina septiembre negro pero al
parecer dos de los terroristas de Munich
siguen vivos uno en Jordania el otro en
el Líbano
a pesar de que son asesinos disfrutan de
sus vidas
y están con sus familias para mí eso es
una injusticia
La viuda de Andrés pitcher el entrenador
del equipo de esgrima israelí lleva 50
años luchando por la verdad
este es sangre frente a la ventana Esa
es la última vez que lo viví
Por qué los alemanes rechazaron la ayuda
de los servicios de inteligencia
israelíes Porque también se negaron a
revelar ciertos documentos el día
siguiente del atentado aquí fue amunic
al apartamento de los atletas allí
volvería muchas veces pero ante sus
preguntas las autoridades alemanas
guardaron silencio durante décadas
en aquella época en los años 70 las
autoridades alemanas y bávaras seguían
hundidas en su oscuro pasado
por decirlo de alguna manera les
importaba un comino
11 judíos más fueron asesinados en suelo
alemán
después de 50 años alguien en Alemania
debe tener por fin el valor de decir No
más lo que quiero oír es una disculpa
pública y un reconocimiento de su total
responsabilidad
El Aniversario número 50 de la masacre
representa una doble Victoria para ella
tras largas negociaciones el gobierno
alemán les pagará 28 millones de euros a
los familiares de las víctimas
[Música]
y el jefe de estado alemán
les pidió perdón públicamente a las
familias de las víctimas
les pido perdón como jefe de estado de
este país y en nombre de la República
Federal de Alemania
Perdón por no haber protegido mejor a
los atletas israelíes Durante los Juegos
Olímpicos de Múnich y por la falta de
información que hubo después
el 5 de septiembre de 2022 en la pista
del aeropuerto
firstenfelbrook es momento de
reflexionar pero también de arrepentirse
ya él chamán goodfront lleva 50 años
esperando este momento era una de las
condiciones para la participación de las
familias en esta conmemoración en
territorio alemán para ella y sus hijos
la memoria de las víctimas finalmente
fue respetada
cuando mi mamá aún vivía siempre me
decía fueron los alemanes quienes
mataron a tu padre y hoy Esta es la
prueba de que todo este tiempo tuvimos
razón
es duro para nosotros las familias es
muy duro muy emotivo pero es un paso que
nos permite mantener Viva su memoria
porque hoy por fin todo el mundo habla
de este Atentado
es una victoria para nosotros y un
consuelo
una victoria quizás también para la
verdad las familias de las víctimas
consiguieron que los últimos documentos
confidenciales en Alemania sean
desclasificados los historiadores
alemanes e israelíes podrán por fin
esclarecer la masacre de Munich
y hasta aquí este boleto de vuelta
recuerde que si le gustó este reportaje
lo puede ver nuevamente a través de
nuestra página web France 24.com hasta
una próxima oportunidad
[Música]